التخطيط المالي للمستقبل والادخار وكيفيه
الاستهلاك امور يجب ان تكون على راس
اولويات كل اسره خاصه في ظل التقلبات
الاقتصاديه التي يشهدها العالم
كانه لانه اللي جاي على قد اللي رايح
مضى كمان طبعا هناك نصائح النصائح
اقتصاديه تقول انتظر 48 ساعه قبل شراء شيء
تركته في سله التسوق الالكترونيه بعدها
قرر اذا ما كنت قد تحتاجه فعلا لن يؤثر
كثيرا على ميزانيتك هذا الشيء صح ضغط
الاجتماعي طبعا هي مشكله اخرى
احتاجها لكن لان الاخرين يملكونها ليس الا
نقاشنا اليوم حول اقتصاد الافراد وكيف
نتوقف عن التبذير تحديدا
سمر الماشطه الصحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد
ضيفتنا وسنتحدث كثيرا عن هذا الامر اهلا
بك صباح الخير سمر صباح الخير صباح الورد
والنور عندي لسان الخبراء وليس عن لساني
لانه
انا من 100
هذه طبيعه بشريه انه انا مثلا يعني الواحد
يقول الدينار بجيبه او الدرهم بجيبه يحكه
لازم يطلع
عن طريق التليفون او الساعه
او يعني مو مثل لما تطلع كاش وتدفع يوجعك
شويه هسا تك تك تك ما تحس فيه ما تلاقي
تدفع فلوس يعني
على طول يعني قديش لازم ندخر من مدخولنا
وشو اكثر
المناحي الحياه اللي منبذر فيها هناك
قاعده ذهبيه متعارف عليها عالميا اللي هي
خمسين ثلاثين عشرين خمسين بالمئه من دخلك
يصرف على الضروريات ايجار اكل وقود
للسياره كهرباء مدارس الضروريات اللي لا
يمكن تستغنين عنها 50% 30% عن واتشي ونت
اشياء تريديها اشياء مثلا الاشياء الفاخره
يعني مثلا بدل ما تشترين حذاء الدو تشترين
حذاء غوتشي 30% تروح على هاي الاشياء اللي
تريديها اللي يضيف لك سعاده بس هي بنفس
الوقت مو ضروريه يعني تقدرين تستغنين عنها
كماليات 20% ادخار كل القواعد حتى كل
بالاقتصاد الثاني اللي يقول لك 80% ما
اعرف ايش 20% لازم يروح على الادخار اذا
انت ما تتمكنين عندك التزامات ماديه ما
تقدرين تدخلين عشرين بالمئه من مدخوله
الشهري على الاقل بلشي من 5% وبعدين ضيفيه
واحد بالمئه كل سنه بس لازم تضيفين
على حساب الكماليات ولا على حساب طبعا
يعني مثلا ما هي المشكله انه كيف يبدا
الشخص دائما نظري
الجزء
الصرف الالكتروني او التسوق الالكتروني ما
بعد كورونا اصبح ادمان
طيب مبدئيا تجيب ورقه تكتب بها الاكسبنسز
الاشياء المصاريف مالتك اللي تصرفها كل
يوم تسجل كل يوم لمده شهر تروح على هاي
المصاريف تشوف تقدر توفر اول شيء اجابه
على الشق الثاني من سؤالك ايضا مساله
الاكل خارج المنزل يعني لازم تخصص وقت مع
تنظيم وقتك لازم تخصص وقت وتجيب معك اكل
الى المكتب بدل ما تطلب من برا ممكن توفر
على نفسك 80% من سعر هذه الوجبه مثلا نبلش
بها عندنا الان مشكله كبيره هي ايضا
الكريدت كاردز الديون اللي علينا زادت
الان الانترا ستريت او الفائده على هاي
الكريد حاولوا تسدوها قدر الامكان او
تمويل من جهه او بنك اخر يعطيكم فائده اقل
سدوا الفائده الاكبر هذا اهم شيء لازم
نركز عليه اخر نصيحه واخر نصيحه لعلامات
الفاخره لما تروح تشتري علامه فاخره غطي
العلامه على الحذاء قول هل اني ادفع 1000
دولار على هذا الحذاء اذا ما كانت عليه
هاي العلامه وشوف هو هذا الشيء اللي بيضحك
انه احنا بندفع هالقد فلوس علشان التجاريه
بس علشان اليوم
ولا جوده المنتج شكرا جزيلا لك
الصحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد شكرا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات